in the old days cards from all the 1960s
at a magnetic strip right so that when
you did a transaction the terminal would
read the data on the card magnetic strip
but from 2003 in the UK you started to
get chips as well so the information is
kept in this semiconductor chip and that
makes it significantly more difficult to
counterfeit it's a counterfeit a
magstripe card all you've got to do is
copy it onto a new card but to
counterfeit a chip you've got to drill
into it with lasers and probing stations
and other expensive fiddly equipment and
get the keys out and that is a pain and
it only works some of the time and you
just don't want to go there but don't
worry if you're a criminal because there
are lots and lots of easier ways of
cheating Chip and PIN systems Chip and
PIN is fun it was designed in the late
1990s on the basis of some earlier
experiments in the earlier 1990s in
which we were privileged to have some
small role and it was introduced first
in Britain from 2003 to 2005 so we
started off with an idea of what the
frauds would likely be for example if
you have got some means of intercepting
the transaction floor between a card and
a terminal so you've got a false card
and you can wire it up to a false
terminal elsewhere then when a sucker
puts his card into your terminal you can
teleport that to a dodgy card that you
then presented a juror shop and we
demonstrated this as a proof of concept
and these relay attacks work in theory
but you don't see them in practice then
once Chip and PIN got fielded we began
to see how things changed in the real
world and fraud didn't in fact go down
but it went up because first of all the
bad guys went online and all thought
fraud initially fell a little bit in
shops it more than caught up for that by
increasing online and second ortho fraud
from cancer fit cards initially went
down when they introduced chip and pin
what happened was an after a period of
six months or so it shot up and what the
bad guys had realizes that now you've
got these chip and
devices everywhere you could use them to
harvest chip-and-pin details card
details and you could then make up
magstripe card forgeries and use them in
ATMs that would still accept mac max toy
transactions so we found for example
that there was a dodgy chip and pin
terminal in the BP garage and Girton
which cost a couple of hundred people
locally to have money taken from their
cash machines in Thailand of all places
and there was a gang that got various
people at garages around the country to
install dodgy equipment that would
capture people's Chip and PIN details so
that was one of the things that went
wrong it was possible for example to
remove part of the back of a chip and
pin terminal and put electronics in
there and drill in so that you got into
the serial link which goes between the
inn pad and the card and that gets the
current details going one direction and
the pin going on the other direction and
that's all that you need to do Mac
strike forgeries after we demonstrated
this on TV the bank said well you know
that's a difficult attack Cambridge
students can do it but real criminals
couldn't but only a few months later
they arrested a couple of guys in
Manchester what they'd done was good
access to the warehouse in Dubai for the
chip and pin terminals start to catch
breath or rip from the factory in China
to the retail trade in Britain and the
Netherlands and in the back of them they
put little mobile phones so that
whenever you use this terminal it would
text your card and PIN details to
somebody in Karachi and those guys
eventually got off because the banks
weren't prepared to offer evidence
against them it was just too
embarrassing more recently what we
discovered is that we got a number of
people came to us and they said look my
card was stolen it was then used in a
shop the bank says it must be my fault
because the pin was used and so I must
have been negligent but it couldn't have
happened I didn't use the carb of the
pin so we went and we looked and we
found that it's actually easy to cheat
because what you can do is you can put a
device between the card and the terminal
which tells the terminal that the pin
was accepted by the card but tells the
card that it was a chip and signature
transaction and this is an example of
the electronics that you can use you put
the stolen card into the device like
this and you then use the same card in
the chip and pin device like this and
this means that the electronics can
modify the transaction as it flows from
your stolen smart card to the chip and
pin terminal the chip and pin machine is
told that you entered the correct pin
even although you didn't but the card is
taught that a signature verified the
transaction and it's this kind of
sleight of hand that enables the door
pin fraud to be carried out and we've
seen that in the wild since gosh about
2010 2011 there are people in France
have been sent to jail for it there's a
number of variants of it and now we're
starting to see it in China because in
China you can buy tiny little two-sided
SIM cards that will go between your
phone on your SIM card to enable you to
do roaming more cheaply right so that
you can roam among China's different
provinces and the problem with these
slim shims is that they're just what you
need to replace all this electronics
things our sim shim is another name in
between yeah exactly so and so these
devices can enable you to replace all
this electronics with one tiny little
chip that you can just slip in between
the stolen card and the chip and pin
terminal well what we're doing is
getting a man-in-the-middle as we call
it in between the card and the chip and
pin machine so we can manipulate those
parts of the transaction that aren't
properly cryptographically authenticated
so that that's the latest fraud
technology the latest fraud methodology
is simpler because what you do is you
take a chip and pin machine and you
reprogram it and we're now seeing evil
Chip and PIN machines coming on the
market in Europe in Spain and Britain in
Portugal in the Baltics and elsewhere
and what these chip and pin machines
will do is they'll display a small
amount on the screen say your
transaction is thirty pounds for you
know a meal or whatever for putting a
big transaction into the card three
thousand pounds okay and these are
typically used in places like nightclubs
and strip
clubs and so on so those various guys
from Britain have you know gone on stag
nights and Poland or in the through any
or whatever and they come back and find
those a five thousand-pound transaction
under chip and pin card how did it
happen well use your chip and pin card
in a strip club in Vilnius what do you
expect or in Barcelona or now even in
Bournemouth this is now happening in
Britain as well and it's very very
difficult for people who go into a bad
place and use a card because if if you
complain to your bank then the strip
club or and I will just say we was with
four girls all night and four thousand
pounds is what that costs at our place
so you're really only hiding - nothing
when it comes to complaining the thing
about this is that the average person
just doesn't think that you know if you
pull your wallets out of your pocket
you've got what two or three cards in
there if each of these cards is good for
five or ten thousand pounds you know
with your overdraft limit and the extra
undocumented overdraft that the bank
will give you and charge you extra for
there's a total spending power in your
pocket of maybe twenty thousand pounds
now you wouldn't dream of walking into a
poorhouse on a Saturday night with
twenty thousand pounds in cash in your
pocket would you but that's what people
do when they walk into dodgy businesses
just carrying a normal wallet with
normal Chip and PIN cards in them and
that's a new hazard that people just
aren't aware of yet
a classic example of the middle person
attack which was John Conway's a famous
idea of how to beat a grandmaster at
chess what's easy you just play two
grandmasters at chess simultaneously by
postal chess and you relay the moves
backwards and fours from one to the
other playing games like this is what
security engineers are really really
into when it comes to designing
protocols and protocols are hard to
design right people usually get them
wrong and again and again we find
protocol flaws with EMV which can be
exploited and are being exploited EMV is
the set the Sunday afternoon aim for
Chip and PIN is European MasterCard Visa
Prosecco